what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing on with our
discussions about the Watchmen in this
video we pick up with the origin of war
Shack now there are a couple things that
happen in this this segment of the story
that don't focus on Rorschach things
like Laurie for example and Dan you know
the fact that Laurie had left dr.
Manhattan she was looking for a place of
her own
dan offers his they sort of you know
touch naughty bits a couple times and
then that's about it things like Adrian
Veidt for example somebody tries to
attack him tries to kill him and then
Adrian Veidt you know is able to
overcome the guy after the guy takes a
cyanide capsule ah those are the kind of
things we saw people who know what's
going on behind the scenes if you know
about this kind of stuff please do not
spoil anything
I've already banned a handful of people
based on you know spoiling Dakin please
do not spoil anything for this so with
regards to the whole idea of war Shack
the cool thing about this is that this
deals with the origin of his character
as well as how he functions now the cool
thing is that initially he breaks into
the house of Moloch remember Moloch is a
guy who was an enemy of dr. Manhattan an
enemy of the comedian and of course the
comedian him dying is really what set
all this in motion in the first place
and so Rorschach showing up to the house
of Mulliken and really interrogating him
is based on what information do you have
that's kind of hidden and what's going
on with somebody going around and taking
out all these masked superheroes and
this is cool because Morlocks initial
response is well I don't really know
anything I mean I can't think of
anything that I know of but if I happen
to come across some information I'll try
to find a way to give it to you
ultimately Rorschach sets up a location
he says hey there's this diner drop
something in there I'll check it you
know I said like 11:30 at night and if
there's anything in there I'll come back
now this is interesting because this is
kind of like a throwback to the old
1960s pyv programs right like you watch
those old movies those spy movies you
know and it deals with the idea of well
you know don't check the same location
every single day and if something's in
there they'll know their mission is
about to engage or they'll get some
information or whatever the case may be
I don't I don't really know spied lingo
at all but you know at this point we
transition over to Rorschach showing
back up later on that night
and of course we're shocked showing up
really comes by way of hey I've got
information for you you know at least
coming from Moloch when were shocked
shows up at Moloch's house Moloch is
basically just sitting there dead with a
hole in his head now this is designed to
frame Rorschach and the reason being
because of the fact that somebody's
trying to remove him off the board and
that's the first thing he picks up on
that if he shows up and that Moloch has
been shot in the head and he's been
killed and basically cops are swarming
left and right then someone's framed him
for this someone set him up and it's
most likely the person trying to get rid
of masked vigilantes trying to get rid
of people who were basically Watchmen
and it's cool because of course he makes
an escape and he tries to get out as
best he can ultimately he subdued by the
cops and he's thrown in jail now this is
when we get to the good part of the
story this is when we get to the really
really cruel stuff so initially we pick
up with a guy named Malcolm long and
Malcolm long is a is such an interesting
character and I really really want you
guys to watch him I want you guys to
really focus on what happens with him
because for his character we're gonna
see this kind of like tumbling down the
rabbit hole with a lot of different
things and that's what makes Rorschach
so interesting but of course initially
workshops put to this sort of ink blot
test where you know it's like well when
you look at this what do you see when
you look at this what do you see and all
the answers he gives or well I see nice
things like pretty butterflies and so on
and so forth and really it's not easy so
that washouts trying to prove it he's
not crazy or anything like that he's not
in an insane asylum he's in an actual
prison so it's not like impressing a
psychiatrist is somehow going to get him
free it's basically just that they're
going through and performing the same
act they've done before now this all
goes back to when he was younger and so
what we're gonna do here is we're
actually gonna deviate away from this
little tidbit of a story for a second
and we're gonna go back before were
shocked really before this story picks
up in terms of what were shocked was
about so in the backup features for
although all the Watchmen comics you'll
find a variety of different stories
you'll find tales about pirates and all
different kinds of things but one of the
things that it does is it runs over
Walter corvax the real name of war shock
and what we end up finding out is in a
1935 his mother had moved from Ohio to
New York along with her husband which I
can't member her husband's name and the
issue is that they divorced about two
years later and it was basically a
mutual divorce you know they were
basically accusing the other of cheating
and you know messing with her head and
different things like that following
this there's no real indication of when
it started happening but Walter corvax
mom began moving into the position of
becoming a woman of the night is this
you know basically the best way to say
it as a result of this somewhere along
the line there was a man named Charlie
and Charlie had basically shacked up
with Rorschach's mom for quite some time
knocked her up and that's where
Rorschach came from but he left like two
months before she gave birth and then
there was no real indication of what
happened next now during that period and
this is where things get a little murky
it seems that the birth of Walter is
what set his mother down the path of the
tonight you know she didn't make enough
money with the whatever job she had in
order to satisfy all the bills that were
piling up and things along those lines
the problem with this is that she
despised her life she hated the life she
lived and she basically took that out on
a Walter every chance she got you know
there were instances where he would walk
in different things like that and she
would basically scream and shoot you
know don't insults at him and I should
have gotten rid of you and different
things along those lines now from here
we kind of jumped back into this whole
discussion with Malcolm long because
that little tidbit is largely left out
now again that's one little backup
features and then everything after that
Walter basically gives us again him
walking in on his mom as a young kid he
didn't really know what he was seeing he
didn't really understand what it was
that he was witnessing and so the result
of this is that his mom just continues
to kind of lash out at him different
things like that
you know she constantly abuses and so on
and so forth and he lives a pretty
heinous life a pretty terrible life in
each of these glimpses into his past
come by way of Malcolm Long's showing
him a Rorschach inkblot test and saying
what do you see when you look at this
and so again that's what's kind of
curious is because in his mind he sees
the worst things in his life but he's
really just kind of telling Malcolm what
he wants to hear and that's what's so
ironic is because Malcolm doesn't want
the truth about what the world's like he
thinks he does but he doesn't because
once he gets it he'll immediately turn a
blind eye and that's that's why this is
designed to be kind of a social
commentary for a lot of different things
that people are like I really want to
know what the world's like I want to see
how hard the world could beat well as
soon as they get that opportunity they
turn tail and run away oh man no and
that's what's so interesting about that
is it it's it's kind of a reflection of
normal people now in terms of him really
beginning to delve into his darker side
this came around the time that he was
about 11 or 12 I think it was and the
result was that he was picked on by a
couple of kids and so what he ends up
doing is just kind of taking it into his
own hands and where these bullies were
giving him a hard time he takes his
cigarette out of one of their mouths and
then puts it out in his eye blinds him
with it and then in turn chews on the
other guy literally starts biting into
him it feeds on this darker nature of
Rorschach the idea that he began kind of
tumbling down this rabbit hole now the
other thing about this is that it also
delves into the nature of Malcolm long
and this is what I want you to notice
when you look at Malcolm long the
initial depiction of his home life is
that his home life is pretty solid was
almost like he has the life that
Rorschach aspires to reward Shaq lives
down in the muck he lives down in the
dirt
every day he's slumming it along every
day he's dealing with the scum and the
terrible nature of humanity up here in
the clouds
you've got Malcolm long you've got
Malcolm long going through and writing
his articles about Rorschach and
spending time with his wife and
presumably spending time with his kids
and they have this nice quaint little
life and so the cool thing about this is
that this is immediately gonna come
tumbling down because what is it
happening is in their next session as
soon as Malcolm long sits down with
Rorschach he keeps calling him Walter
and were shocked responses I don't like
that now on the surface it seems like
Walter is just kind of like I don't like
it when you call me were shocked because
I want to call myself Rorschach that's
not the case in fact in the mind of
Rorschach Walters dead and he's been
dead for quite some time and that's when
we start getting into this and so again
in order to fill in these gaps a little
bit in terms of what the comic gives us
versus what the backup features give us
following the incident where he had
attacked those two guys and helped them
to understand their place in the bigger
picture the result is that he gained the
attention of authorities and so when
they went to investigate his home life
they realized all the abuse he was
suffering at the hands of his mom and he
was yanked out from that house and
thrown into a school for boys the issue
is that his mom never came to see him
she never came to talk to him or
anything like that presumably she just
kept spiraling down the self-destructive
pattern ultimately leading to her death
and so while he was there when they came
to him and they said hey man your mom's
died he's just like good the world is
rid of one less useless human being and
so following that once he was out he was
16 years old he went out into the world
he got a job at a garment factory and
this is cool because what he ended up
discovering is that kind of you know
where dr. Manhattan was a relatively
popular theme at the time if somebody
had basically ordered a dress of sorts
that had you know like two I guess two
layers and between those layers was a
you know I guess a shape-changing
material of some kind but what it
basically managed it would change shape
based on the temperature of the person's
body but when the person who ordered it
got it they didn't like it so they
basically discarded it and so Rorschach
took it for himself and that's where he
gets his mask from that's why his mask
moves around the way it does it's a
custom material that changes shape based
on the temperature of the person the
problem with this and in terms of him
becoming a vigilante this all stemmed
from the fact that there was an incident
that took place with a girl named kitty
Genovese and Kitty Genovese was
assaulted and then killed by a guy or
something like that but the entire
neighborhood while this was all going on
look down watched it happen and didn't
do anything about it but it set him on
the path of realizing if there are
people in the world who were gonna watch
such a terrible thing happen and do
nothing to stop it then this can't just
be the only time that would happen and
so that's when he sits around and says
well society is the way it is because
people make it that way because there's
no concern because people say I don't
care what goes on in the world until it
affects me this is designed to be a very
cynical perspective of the world there's
a lot of great things that happen in the
real world but for worse Shaq he doesn't
see that in his world he doesn't see
that all he sees is the terrible things
that happen and that's kind of the irony
because Malcolm long basically makes
this argument well I think that you've
been conditioned to see things this way
but your mother's abuse for you has
conditioned you to the point that this
is all you see because it's all you've
known and this was kind of funny is
because there's truth to that I would
like to believe people are one part
nature one part nurture that's sure
there is an instinct in people in terms
of us reacting to scenarios
fight-or-flight different things like
that but the factory majors also the
nurture side that if I take a child and
I put them in a room and I show them
nothing but violence all they're going
to come to believe is that violence is
okay and the world is nothing but
violence if I take people and I removed
them from social settings and I take
away any form of human interaction and
raise them that way from the time
they're a child and then send them out
into the world they're not gonna know
how to interact with people it's not a
natural instinct for people to be able
to carry on conversations it's a skill
set that's learned if it was a natural
instinct you wouldn't have people who
didn't know how to hold conversations it
is an interesting concept when it comes
to nature versus nurture and how it
works with the character of horshack but
when Walter looks at Malcolm long he
doesn't see a man that's genuinely
trying to help him but what he sees is a
man that's just trying to make his bones
that's how Rorschach sees him and truth
I wouldn't say Malcolm long is
duplicitous I'd say he's a guy who's
just curious about how he works he's
curious what makes him tick and now of
course for were shocked himself also
keep in mind Walter Kovacs is not a man
to be trifled with and a lot of people
who were currently in this prison are
there because he put them there and so
it is kind of funny because there are
people who are trying to make their
bones by being the ones to take out
Rorschach and one of the guys makes the
mistake of believing he has the upper
hand and the result is that were Shaq
splashes them with hot grease literally
all down his face and it's crazy because
when you're Malcolm long and you're
learning about these kind of things and
you're studying this kind of person it
almost becomes an obsession and that's
why I wanted you guys
to notice his life because his
relationship with his wife begins to
become a bit strenuous so instead of his
wife coming in and saying hey are you
almost done he's like yeah yeah you know
it's about eight o'clock you know let's
go ahead and wind down for the night now
he's up for hours and hours and hours
it's almost like he's ignoring his wife
it's gotten to a point where war Shaq is
an obsession for him and so from there
we pick up with this next session knock
along ask the question when did Walter
corvax cease to exist at what point was
it no longer Walter corvax and at what
point did you full-on become Rorschach
and that's what's interesting is because
he says in the early days of being a
masked vigilante I didn't really
understand what I was getting into I was
young I was naive I genuinely believed
that I could change the world all the
while failing to realize if the world
could have been changed that easily
somebody would have changed it already
the way this all progressed I joined the
Watchmen thing we could do incredible
and amazing things I genuinely believed
in the superhero escapades he makes
comments on the comedian that the
comedian realized how terrible and awful
people were he has respect for the
comedian because a comedian seems to be
the only person that really looks at
humanity for what it is as opposed to
looking at humanity for what it could be
now these are distinctly interesting
philosophical views when it comes to
this and that's what's so cool people
will say in order to be able to fix the
world you have to imagine it for what it
could be the world can never become
greater than what it is if you never
look at what it could be and that's true
but if you look at the problems the
world has you have to look at it like an
illness a doctor cannot walk up to a
patient that's suffering from some kind
of illness and say okay I know exactly
how to fix you because I'm imagining you
being cured no they have to know what
the problem is they have to know what
the source of that sickness is and then
treat that source and that's how
Rorschach and how comedian view the
world now the steps they take to try to
quote-unquote fix the world well of
course that's a whole different argument
you know a whole other kettle of beans
but for them among the members of the
watchmen they're the only ones who
really see the world for what it is
they're the ones who only really see the
core the problem is people before the
problem is humanity in the eyes of
comedian and the eyes of Walter corvex
the cause of the problem is as human
beings now we're were shaq believes that
if he kills enough bad guys then bad
things will stop happening the comedians
just like as long as there's people in
this world terrible things are gonna
happen and so there's no point in trying
to stop it because until humanity
becomes extinct terrible things are just
gonna keep happening and happening and
happening and that's why he just laughed
but for Rorschach he stopped being
Walter when he had been informed
about a young girl who had essentially
vanished you know this girl named Blaire
Roche and so the result is that he had
gone around a he'd start started poking
around and trying to find different
clues and things like that who would
lead to her location ultimately leading
him to a house well I say house but it
was more like a garment shop but the
fact remains that it was owned by a guy
named Gerald Grice and Joel Grice had
kidnapped this young girl under the
belief that her parents owned a fortune
and he'd be able to extort ransom the
problem with this was that wind war shot
got in there what he found was that the
girl had actually been killed by a
Gerald and fed to the dogs
and so this snapped something in the
mind of Walter corvax
at that moment he stopped being Walter
and became Rorschach because it was the
most heinous thing he'd seen to that
point it was such a terrible disregard
for human life and for such a young girl
at six years old it was insane and it
was brutal and the result was that he
did exactly what he should have done he
killed both dogs and then he turned
turned his weapon on on Gerald Grice or
at least not seem to turn his weapon on
Gerald Rice now in the movie he just
started hacking at him you know with an
axe in the comic uh he did something
that Gerald definitely deserved what he
ended up doing was chaining Gerald up
and then setting the place on fire and
allowed Gerald to just kind of burn
alive he literally just just cooked that
guy alive and forced him to die a slow
painful death
but as he was watching this happen
Rorschach came to the realization that
there is no hope for Humanity though
there's only ever bad things all you can
do is stem the tide but if there's no
one there to be Rorschach if there's no
one there to be the gatekeeper and to
keep things from wiling out of control
then eventually the evil nature of
humanity will engulf the entirety of the
planet that humanity will just push
itself to a point where everything will
come to an end and that's the argument
Rorschach routinely uses and he even
uses the set of events at the time to
justify that he looks around he says not
only are people doing these terrible
things on the street level but look at
the governmental level you've got
crooked politicians you've got people
who abuse drugs you've got countries
waging war against one another using
nuclear weapons that would lead to the
complete and total extermination of
humanity because they're vying for power
and that's why these psychological and
philosophical analyses of work Shack
stand the test of time that's why
decades after the Watchmen was written
these analysis of work shacks still work
because people take these concepts and
they apply them to the modern day 2012
kony appeared and for the
summer of 2012 everybody was gonna
change the world man we're gonna fix
Africa we got Kody out there and he's
this dictator using child soldiers and
we're gonna fix it all we're gonna we're
gonna make everything okay people were
changing their facebook profile pictures
twitter hashtag campaigns a whole nine
yards and then school started back and
that was the end of that you have this
concept of war Shaq who looks around and
says man the world's at a terrible place
people are raising awareness for things
and you know people are being activists
as long as it's convenient for them but
then as soon as it becomes inconvenient
well then they have a litany of things
to do and they can't miss their favorite
shows but the fact remains here that
these are the kind of things that war
Shaq looks around and sees and says this
is the nature of humanity if people
really wanted the world to be a better
place it would be a better place the
reason why it's not a better place is
because people don't care enough to try
enough and that's the case that's used
here with Malcolm long Malcolm long is
being introduced to a world that he
wanted to ignore that he didn't want to
believe truly existed but being forced
to see it being given this first-hand
account by Rorschach of this heinous
crime means that he can't ignore it
anymore it's now becoming an ingrained
part of his personality and where this
event where this young girl had changed
the way that war Shaq sees the world
it's also changing the way Malcolm long
sees the world and notice this
juxtaposition notice this when he sits
down at dinner with his wife and a
couple of family friends one of the
things they ask is so what's going on
with war Shaq like how's that whole
thing going you know and he's like well
actually war Shaq told me about a
kidnapping case it happened in 1975 and
and one of them is like man what
happened like what she gagged was she
help us it's almost like this seedy
underbelly of the world is a zoo for
those individuals who were disconnected
from the way the world really is and
that's what happens when this guy starts
asking these questions and when he's so
excited about what happened to this girl
who was kidnapped because it's so
fascinating we're not gonna long it
gives him this play-by-play on what
happened well then suddenly the realism
is just too much to bear suddenly as
well I mean look man that's that's
that's that's crazy and they you know
they basically end up splitting but
that's the crazy thing about this that's
why it's so intriguing is because
Malcolm along his wife leaves him his
family just comes crumbling down around
him and all the while he begins looking
at all these little ink blot tests and
he's coming to the same conclusion that
Rorschach is maybe there is no hope for
Humanity the reaction of his family
friends to hearing the grittiness in the
true nature of the world they can't
handle it they run away and so maybe
that's what it is
maybe it's humanity's inability to
accept the world
and to either put blinders on or should
just look the other way and so Malcolm
long doesn't have that option knuckle on
doesn't have the ability to look the
other way he stuck there with Rorschach
and even if he packed his bags and he
quit and said I'm not doing this anymore
because of what he's heard and because
of what he's seen there's no going back
there's no way to undo what he's
experienced so far more Shaq is part and
parcel to Malcolm long and that's why
it's so cool is because Rorschach is a
name and Rorschach's and identity that
Walter corvax uses to justify his
actions but it's an ideology Rorschach
stands for the very concept that
sometimes the world is beyond any real
hope of saving and the only thing that
you can do is try to stem the tide and
when people begin to wake up and they
begin to realize what's truly happening
their names get cast aside who they were
beginning to move on and they become
warsha
they become this ideology this
embodiment that someone has to stem the
tide so again it's cool it's a really
interesting concept because it takes
this guy Malcolm long whose life is up
in the clouds and he's got no real
understanding of what the world's like
and it sends him spiraling down into
this cesspool of how the world really is
through the eyes of Walter corvax
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob port you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]